I heard a rumor you and your wife are
hanging out with a black couple this
weekend potential swinging is that true
yes and you are going to swing with them
when probably in a couple of weeks a
couple of weeks like small set yeah yeah
it's all set drinks and then we went to
this place that has dancing and a DJ and
then I ended up at the end of the night
standing on a street corner in Jersey
City the two girls made out then I made
out with a girl and she made out with a
guy there was this guy standing there
looking like [ __ ] is going on here
people have seen pictures of this couple
that you have shown around the office
and just just just as surely so does the
guy have a big pecker I have no idea he
said the guy's enormous I don't know
what that means I saw pictures of this
couple and I think Brent's completely
out of his element
I think this guy I think his wife's
leaving him and the three of them are
gonna start a new things you know looks
like he could break both of them and
have a break so and you're telling me
when this guy is [ __ ] your wife
probably has a nice big [ __ ] 15 inch or
yeah you're not gonna get crazy no no
you are a swinger swingers swings well
he's all set up for it it's making at a
time know what his reaction is gonna be
really telling Robin I'm not completely
inexperienced in this area the point
this is a new experience ish when you
meet up are you pretending like you're
not about to [ __ ] the guy's wife is
there small talk for a while before you
get into it
no that's the beauty of this is you're
not pretending that you're not gonna
[ __ ] the guy's wife you're like your
time talking to this guy about what she
likes and what you know we're then how
isn't the deal closed if everybody knows
what they're there for
like they'd always end on a make out it
never goes past that [ __ ] do you speak
it it takes some time to get her why's
there a second make out after the first
big what you saying is that brent has
never successfully I think he's the
factor I think he's the x-factor
really I think I think he creeps him out
I think he's the stick in the [ __ ]
wheel you have no idea you have no idea
what the [ __ ] you're talking what
about you he's saying yes right with a
good buzzing he gets a stare on him I
mean I know is my wife's attractive guy
sure so it's true it must be Brent
that's scaring away all these swingers
how is this so difficult
well I do want to see Brent dance I
can't even imagine are you are you a
good dancer good would be stretching it
I been out with them Howard I've never
seen Brent dance Kaitlin does you can
dance and it doesn't look bad good
enough to get by that's a lot of
grinding on the check more than are you
the realities I think he wants it so
badly that he's turning them off that's
completely wrong that is completely you
just yours making [ __ ] up I have a
question for burns
are you worried like what would happen
if the guy jizz then it got on you
sizing me into your section are you
prepared for that it's probably not
gonna happen since we use condoms come
on you know Shirley you're standing in
front of the poster of my new book yeah
no I'm saying with my head of hair
against Shirley's head sure it looks
like Shirley has hair it's not a bad
look for you I'll be honest 79 I have to
agree with Shirley that the process is
getting late you know if you want a
romance you do what you did when you
meet Caitlyn you have a long build-up
and you get involved with each other
swinging is about not getting involved
it's getting comfortable with the
situation
this is swinglish swinger
you'll eventually get his wings